le quiero empezar planteando que a
medida que las sociedades abren debates
por ejemplo sobre la identidad de género
estos a debates se trasladan al uso del
lenguaje y a la representación le
pregunto Cuáles son los principales
argumentos a favor y en contra de
ampliar el vocabulario para dar cabida a
todas las representaciones
Hola buenas tardes Muchas gracias por la
invitación
Bueno la verdad que es muy muy
interesante la pregunta que me hiciste
porque Bueno desencadena una serie de
debates y de controversias el lenguaje
inclusivo en realidad o lenguaje
incluyente no también como se conoce
este en gran parte de latinoamérica y
también de España no podemos decir que
es un cambio lingüístico todavía porque
para que haya un cambio lingüístico
tiene que ser utilizado por toda la masa
de hablantes Entonces tenemos que
esperar unas décadas para ver si bueno
justamente podemos hablar de un cambio y
de un cambio en la lengua no porque
tenemos que pensar que el lenguaje
inclusivo supone una serie de cambios
morfológicos que se aplican a todo el
sintagma no por ejemplo a partir del uso
de la e por eso podemos hablar ahora de
que se trata de una intervención
discursiva es decir diferentes este
grupos de hablantes utilizan estos
recursos que en la oralidad se destaca
Bueno por el uso de la e pero también en
la escritura se remonta Bueno hasta hace
unos años el arroba no era muy utilizado
también el asterisco pero ahora
principalmente se utiliza la x bueno los
argumentos a favor tienen que ver bueno
justamente con o sea hacer visible no en
la lengua estos este cambios que tienen
que ver con Mostrar las diversidades
sexo genéricas es decir aquellas este
aquella población que justamente no se
corresponde o no se identifica con la
diferencia femenino mas con el binarismo
Y entonces por eso abogan por estos usos
bueno en este sentido sabemos que
muchísimas este posiciones en contra y
tienen que ver más que nada con una
visión más que nada purista de la lengua
es decir bueno no tiene que cambiar la
lengua y también por esta cuestión bueno
que son grupos minoritarios que quieren
cambiar el idioma en este sentido bueno
Tenemos que tener en cuenta que la
lengua no cambia por voluntad de un
determinado grupo sino que bueno
justamente
como yo les decía hace un ratito con con
las décadas vamos a ver si este cambio
este tiene asidero o no Claro Carolina
Porque detrás de todos estos argumentos
una pregunta que me surge Y supongo que
a gran parte de nuestra audiencia es
hasta en qué medida el lenguaje moldea
nuestro mundo o más bien solamente lo
nombra no
exactamente lo que pasa es que a ver
tenemos que ver que la lengua es cambio
no no O sea no no hay nada estático
pensemos que no hablamos igual no sé si
pensamos Cien años ni hace diez años
Entonces estos cambios van a ir
surgiendo Es cierto que hay que ver si
se asimilan en la lengua o no Si por ahí
quedan en esta manifestación disruptiva
o de protesta y de intento bueno por una
cuestión política de mostrar estas
disidencias sexo genéricas o no o si
después se introduce por ejemplo este
algún pronombre neutro o este o si la es
no como un cambio morfológico se va este
asentando es cierto que no podemos este
darle la espalda a los cambios no que
hay en la en la sociedad y justamente
vos que hablabas de este tema no de que
hoy se celebra el Día de la lengua
española pero yo creo que en El Siglo 21
podemos pensar esto que la lengua
española
son variedades discursivas no son todas
esas variedades que se producen en los
diferentes este lugares ciudades pueblos
de España y latinoamérica por eso no
podemos hablar de una lengua pura
neutraséptica sino que la lengua es eso
es variedad